e siamo tornati ben ali ragazzi ciao a
tutti
abbiamo fatto gli ultimi test funziona
tutto quindi perché non arriva un bel
fulmine non sto scherzando
un bacio a tutti grazie di esservi
connessi lega
oggi facciamo la seconda semifinale
della suap challenge by vodafone ve la
spiego tra un secondo aspetto che si
connettano tutti intanto vi saluto
vi piace sono contento che vi sia
piaciuto che si dona un ricordo che ho
nella copertina l'ho fatto stamattina ho
detto beh sì come gioco con il giorgione
nazionale voglio mettere una foto che
sia che si dice che che renda giustizia
insomma la mia persona ho messo quella
spero che sia passato il concetto
buongiorno ragazzi buon pomeriggio a
tutti
state bene sono madonna
no no vi spiego questo ho voluto
utilizzare la stessa maglia di ieri non
ho lui costume da unicorno perché ci
sono 86 gradi potrei di sciogliermi live
quindi ragazzino no quello però grazie
per avermi fatto notare non è kate
perché avevo il costume da unicorno
quello non lo posso mettere ciao ragazzi
sono no sono a milano attualmente non
potete vedere dal mio sfondo bellissimo
so che non siete abituati dai video
perché ho registrato tanti video quando
ero a mettere la torino però adesso sono
tornato e nelle live
la mattina così come adesso potete
vedere che sono sfondo nuovo perché
sotto la nato a tutta mia ciao ragazzi
marco berry pari allora ve la spiego
velocemente per chi non lo sapesse però
è difficile edifici non saperlo lo stavo
dicendo allora vodafone organizzato
questa suap challenge come vi dicevo la
svap challenge che cosa significa si
ficca grazie per la donation nova
significa che
partiamo da una ci sono due semifinali
id mia e di giorgio e poi c'è una
semifinale che stanno giocando si stanno
giocando paolo cannon esterni cosa vuol
dire cioè questa suap challenge ovvero
un giocatore deve giocare al gioco dove
non ha la padronanza un vero gioco che
non è suo
ad esempio io giocherò awards con power
and power ieri sul suo canale sul canale
abbiamo giocato a rocket league e se l'è
cavata anche molto bene
oggi io ho come ospite il power one
nazionale giocheremo awards
proverò a vedere se sono all'altezza
insomma delle sue skill ricordatevi
molto importante dalle 15 alle 16 quindi
è già partita da questa cosa
sulle storie di vodafone votate se sono
stato in grado di di essere all'altezza
appunto del gioco di power voi potete
votare sulle storie di vodafone
instagram andate sul sul profilo
vodafone.it di instagram c'è anche in
descrizione solo se volete per le
comunità mi votate la ragazzi se sono
stato in grado di fare questa cosa spero
di essere stato in grado grazie mirko
grazie christian vediamo di riuscire a
fare una cosa decente io spero spero
davvero di esserne in grado perché come
si dice in genere sa una pippa
però vediamo dice a fare cose fatte bene
allora abbiamo qua con noi il giorgione
aspetto che ti metto ciao giorgione come
stato ragazzi al carichi io più o meno
speriamo che siano tutti i carichi
perché più o meno no io no io sono
carico e chemical co addosso lo sai già
ieri chicca cava addosso terrà gioco mio
figurati al gioco duro ma vai tranquillo
ma vai tranquillo anzi per tutto
dobbiamo tra l'altro questa con
bellissime crossover episode comune
come mostro che stiamo facendo tra tra
borzoli e eccetera eccetera quindi tutti
i giochi awards sono uomo formata da
gioco però con gli amici un po come te
giochi a rocket quindi ragazzi non vi
aspettate ninja però abbiamo il boom
power spero di vincere almeno con te
perché però ha vinto solo due volte
quindi sarà difficile perché siamo in
giù sul tuo contro il trio quindi sarà
non sarà semmai 2t e basta no non hanno
messi allora sarebbe bellissimo tramonto
rom per due io promesso
vorrei cioè possiamo inventarci qualcosa
e addirittura invitare una persona della
cia terranno a inventarci una cosa
allora allora cosa prima di iniziare
prima di iniziare questa sfida giusto
per ricordarlo velocemente è una sfida
organizzata tra noi conta in credo che
dobbiamo praticamente a sfidarci su bari
su vari giochi quindi ragazzi se fa dj
sara abbastanza bravo deve deciderlo voi
ok volgono il vostro supporto perché
potrete andare a votare nelle storie
instagram
in questo caso di vodafone e scegliere
in questo caso chi dei due ovviamente ha
giocato meglio gioco dell'altro il chi
andrà poi in finale contro paolo quando
nello step che mi pare giocheranno
domani se non sbaglio è esatto e poi tra
l'altro la finale la finalissima sarà
tra una settimana circa poi seguite le
storie che ve lo facciamo sapere di
preciso
comunque sia lodata la connessione come
sempre
partiamo visto che in questo ma c è
pronto alle classi doni io so già preso
gioco quindi si cielo pronte ai già
pronte delle classi cioè a dimmi solo
una cosa
tra le specialità ce l'hai fantasma e
sangue freddo spyros elio questa l'unica
cosa fare quando i miei amici giocano
senza fantasma e sangue freddo metti
sempre sempre facendo sì ce l'abbiamo e
dobbiamo allora ti dico solo o un
m4 di secondaria cioè la hdr va bene
algeri corrisposta eccessiva no no no no
sono due casa nel senso che la prendi
cielo quindi dopo al secondo klaus è
perfetto va bene dai più giovani il
gravo invece grau mamma mi allarma in
particolare le premesse ci sono manca il
giocatore però speriamo che funzioni lo
stesso allora allora li accettato la
richiesta
io avevo richieste d'amicizia mi dove si
accetta sì ma di parma ma per azione
prima arriva partecipo da tempo
partecipano vai vai siamo partecipati a
vicenda tipo si infila derivati a
vicenda
poi ci sono sei la vedo l'ora che se non
ci becchiamo qualcuno in squadra
ok faccio quindi contento squadra no
molto bene vado il cibo come esca da
questa cosa che stiamo facendo delle
life così che io sono cioè sono nella
tua live con la mia con la mia camera ma
infatti io te lo dico per me questa è
magia e la guardia è stata una mano
incredibile io questa cosa non la sapevo
neanche è veramente troppo [ __ ] però
penso che bello che un tempo quando si
facevano queste cose era solitamente il
capitolo sincrono cadeva la sua gamba e
giocava con un'altra persona certo è io
ho su youtube si registrava poi il video
l'altra persona a passarlo io invece con
internet che siamo tutti e due fasi ha
tranquillamente abbiamo fatto questa
magia di metterci in chiamata con la
canna e si possono vedere anche me qua
c'è questa cosa bella sia in evoluzione
nel tempo pensa che io il tempo
io non so come facevi tu però visto che
gioca momento la mia coda ai tempi che
non avevamo ancora skype io avevo il
telefono cordless e chiamato il mio
amico per giocare ai tempi ma una roba
conosceva ti si cuoceva l'orecchio è un
po eagle cordless me lo ricordo perché
prendeva fuoco ad un tempo di utilizzo
ori ragazzi orribile
una roba va bene siamo partiti spero di
fare bella figura innanzitutto grazie
tania e ammiro grazie mille ragazzi
grazie a tutti gli abbonati nuovi poi vi
leggo in chiusura perché ragazzi devo
concentrarmi e importante poi vengo per
bene grazie mille vamonos allora spero
di rendere giustizia ti giuro sono sono
i tre non le mani io come ti dicevo ieri
to sotto pressione secondo me sei molto
meglio deve però ti devo alzarmi secondo
il volume alzano perché c'è il volume di
modern warfare che permette il 7 qual è
il microfono o poi trovato tg2 abbiamo
cercato di capire qual era un attimino
confuso
allora era quasi più perfetto perfetto
prova prova proprio prova ma noi
proviamo ora una bomba belen di di
solito cioè dove ti piace alternare ti
giuro che non ho mai una preferenza
andiamo li guardi c'è un posto che ti
piace di più storici da un di base
andavo però restano però non è
indifferente realtà c'è un modo per
evitare che vedi vedere le continuamente
le richieste d'amicizia perché non avevo
mai fatto il a riguardo non mi stanno
arrivando a me dovresti mettere dalle
impostazioni account a di rifiutare
tutte le richieste d'amicizia tysk
impostazioni ok siete amicizia mi
riporti 29 prima che pure l'auto declino
se vuoi
ok modalità streamer che caccia e
nascondere i nomi dei giocatori da
mandare quindi quando la società con già
che ci siamo andiamo storicità un amico
mio vediamo che facciamo una bella
planata lunga dai e proviamo
già la planata già la plata è un casino
devi aprire e chiudere il paracadute
soggiornato per ogni mille cose proprio
base perché io
io gioco a scazzo 15 ho paura del nord
in amore
raga ricordatevi prestate attenzione
alla performance che mi dovete votare
nelle storie di vodafone avete no un ora
è al massimo perché alle 4 verso le 4 si
chiude quindi o poi lo ripeto è
difficile sfortunatamente war zone
specialmente in due quindi ragazzi siate
clementi aree buoni spesa
siate clementi assolutamente allora
secondo me sto andando abbastanza bene
bene già la planata e la votare positiva
sta andando bene
kimi un attimo secondo te arriva gente
fin qua o stiamo tranquilli ma arrivare
arrivano a mannaggia la gente si sparge
per tutta la mappa la mappa sembra
grande ma non lo è
ecco frutto quella riforma e inter molto
più grande
molto più grossa ci siamo sotterrato qua
non c'è daniele modo spero di durare più
di un minuto rega abbiamo già gente
vicino ok al campanile ok arriva il
camion è quello line gennaio
tu dici che ci stream questi gesti
potrebbe succedere che ci sterminata
state buoni infami gli infami ci sono
sempre ok se non hai amici non ho io
tutti e tutto ok ci dormi uguali quindi
facciamo
cerchiamo di fare 10 mila dollari così
andiamo subito la cassa vabbè fa vide lo
fa in un'oretta slim
forse ma non è anche se non è manco del
milan allora facesse una cassa 15 che
aiutava hanno sparato non come di giochi
giugno è infatti mamma mia sono pure
lontani in senso morto dal gulag già
capito almeno che non corri come un
puledro e non so dove sono io non mi
hanno sparato da fuori gioco dentro io
sto dentro quasi dentro questa qua
dentro da me sta qua non mi ha visto la
forte ma questo tipo bear grylls da qua
bravo e io ero tu no no non c'è preso
che sfiga ma non ci per il gioco delle
indie rock e renderà orgoglioso nel july
bene
la partenza è ottima ragazzi devo
scappare via però io non ho la mia io ho
sparato ma stava uno a caso cioè
tranquillo qua o storici stavano molto
di molto difficile infatti noi andiamo
ma per fare che siamo finiti
proprio allora che in base a come va al
ghul anche ricordatevi votarmi su
vodafone.it da fornite instagram non in
base a come si è morto adesso e dove
cercare di capire dove sono andati nora
che a porta nei sarebbe stato per me
molto peggio fidatevi perché poi c'è il
fattore costruzioni e lì non esiste non
esiste proprio dai e il volo che lo
faccio arruolare ragalo fatto cura che
votatemi su instagram devo cerchiati fa
leva sulle cose che sono positive perché
saranno veramente poche perché non
scegli lending con la rotta alle tue
spalle ma si è un'ottima idea
una bellissima idea se farò a volte non
lo farò è questo qua c'è già un team che
sta arrivando
allora che fa
no no no stanno combattendo tra di loro
ma io vengo da te so proprio lì voglio
stato 40 per quello poi il prenderti le
tue armi se vuoi bella questa
questi un altro team oddio che in alto
della norma altri da nord a sud a nord e
uno da sud sono faccia il gulag arrivo
la bibbia
dove cerca di resistere il più che altro
non riesco arriva qua sopra dove cercare
i camper armela finché non arrivi
speriamo che non arrivi nessuno sono sa
che il problema è lo in quattro secoli
prima dei 6
ricordati che mi hai una nord a sud
dovresti cercare pro forse di provare a
uscire da lei che cos'è il nord va bene
beh in altro può vedere come nord e sud
nord per rendere un po più piccante il
tutto era calvino di giornata e questo
perché è talmente epica come come colla
perché lo ritengo questo quindi regala
potete riguardare la vita dimmi con dai
vinto perché io mi sto girano i pollici
nel gulag e non saliamo tirandolo spiega
non devo resistere aiuto ma non sparate
ok stavamo fatto fuori il c4 solo ha
posto ancora sono ancora a posto metto
una mina di prossimità della porta
ok ma mi apro sta portando non lo so io
chiamo programma di incesto scontro
provaci project devono esistere qualcosa
come 30 secondi lega perfetto l'aspetto
è ora devo andare
non posso andare dove sei tu dimmi dove
che mi sposto devo cercare di capire
dove sono io vado verso di lauda ha
rubato un aiuto sopra mi è esplosa la
mia amica e mi ha fatto fuori aspetto
aspetto però fare dei soldi però fuori
dei soliti niente preoccupato
è questo qua è entrato gli ho sparato
gli esplosivi a mina gli ho sparato di
nuovo con sito lui aveva il fallo in
mano che è colpo single e le palle di
genere nel massimo non è proprio il
massimo numero di questa è la mia morte
classica questo gioco fumo molto meglio
di quest'altro è un cecchino è un
cecchino il fallo è un fucile d'assalto
a colpo singolo ti devi spaccare
praticamente l'indice per sparare con
quell'arma non è una cavolata ma a me è
venuta la tendinite con il fatto giuro
ho avuto la tendinite allin praticamente
alla mano destra all'indice per colpa di
queste cose
madonna
perché può capitare
no no ma cgc non voglio da te non si
sente l'audio lo devi accendere amico
mio ciao ragazzi e saluto tutti questa
che stava era allora io mi sento in
dovere di di fatah telecronista al buon
giorgio anche se non ne ha bisogno
quindi tu che cacchio buona e uno a
quella storage erano ricordiamo ha fatto
fuori di quelli che tra ucciso prima io
i soldi ma dolore uno shock che il
vicino venditore perché se vado
all'aereoporto ho paura di beccare gente
ok io ne stava davanti dove mi porta a
cuore di più che altro vorrei evitare
capito perché non ha certo certo
perché se riescono arrestarti un aspetto
questa prova la prenda se penso sia il
miglior shop
quello però vediamo se è aperto ecco se
anche quando aprì vicino ai tavoli e non
si vede ragazzi perché è sotto la mia
webcam nasce giorgio minacciato da vinai
eccolo la stanno arrivando io ti resto
scappa di un campo che è stata chiesta
la portata di una cava aiuto prestato
devi scappare subito lo dico perché
stanno venendo in uno allora se vogliamo
possiamo andare lì sopra ok io vado lì
sopra
vai pure dove pure vado sopra a voi
detto litigato di se stessi si però
cerchiamo dell'utri in quell'anno sul
posto dio mio grazie del resto
com'è morta l'equipaggiamento vogliono
bono si è perché ho pianto le cose che
ha chiesto roba amico di trattrici
leggendaria dai meglio di niente
abbiamo pure un gruppo che vicino
buonissimo no ma però ma però non solo
non ho colpi di milano con un cecchino
da dove dio restato se io ovviamente
solo colpito la mitraglietta chat
forse c'era non posso proprio visti
c'è un ne vedo uno attacca grappolo
buono da sotto andato giù
buono che c'erano della tempesta
la fame capi si contavano cesar e
qualcuno non credo ma 15 stanno
veramente cioè che social non
controllino e ma scusami eh perché
abbiamo la taglia sulla testa ok
perfetto tutto chiaro adesso io non
posso fa credo niente non ho mai capito
aspetta che sto cercando di snap e rare
uno che se riesco io ho tirato un
coltello un chilometro solo pio ne
escono da casa
ok ti ricordi quando provi a tirare i
coltelli a caso per perché bellissima ma
mi sa che gli stessi membri quelli belli
io ci ho provato quando uno è sciolta ma
che non ha poca vita davvero sono
concepiti come senti una cosa orribile
va bene poiché abbiamo la macchina
scambiava avere limiti allora potremmo
provare ad andare sullo shop però la
vedo dura
peccato c'è pieno dice chirurgia non si
deve fare museo mi arrivano salgono un
po sottoposto po di tutto perso
sta salendo l'altro mannaggia è la è ti
sparano amore da dietro ci dobbiamo
buttare a breve ma questo lo abbiamo
fatto un altro soffrì noi ma se tu no no
fatto fatto fatto fatto sapevo che mi
arrivò rivelate prendi di lutto premi di
lutto si riesce a capire
addio cavolo pieno di gente
ma veramente mannaia vengo da te non
cercare mare lontano una mezza di acida
che prima la macchina via la macchina
arriva il tris ma il gas
lascio la maschera va bene quest'anno
spara pure qua e non solo per quello che
ti dice se riesce bene la macchia vengo
in strada
il freddo vengo in strada vai a vedere
che male non manda giù hanno capito che
sfiga ci stavano aspettando
e vabbè dai e sarà questa pedina che sì
ci credo non ci credo
e incredibile per un millimetro questa
era proprio toni vienimi a prendere come
segreto proprio la sfiga l'extra
riguardo ma poi tu non puoi capire
quanta gente c'era c'era un team sopra
superstar 1 sotto e stavamo tutti
aspettando noi
incredibile non è che nei fatti fuori
tra l'altro odio lo sai che non
amministra tipo 65 termini o altro 5
affetto ai ragazzi ora ma il problema è
stato quello che all'inizio non siamo
riusciti a trovare l'ufficio hanno
ammazzato da dietro entrambi a te uno da
dietro poi non sono infallibile quando
sei tornato mi hanno preso a metà dietro
un altro team
e vabbè io spero che tu non vada mai
riguarda questa live e che come sono
molti a non guardare niente di quello
che ho fatto
guarda che io non lo so tutto
l'idea c'era veramente gli ho sparato
proiettili a salve ma per niente un ex
con e riscalda amici siamo riscaldati
anche il rocket ieri ci avevo riscaldati
e poi abbiamo iniziato a giocare quindi
tranquillo il quale partire sono molto
lunghe tra trovare la partita la nobile
adesso ci mettiamo una vita ogni volta
perché è inesatto sa però ci sta ci sta
allora non salutari innanzitutto raga
grazie aver partecipato vi ricordo come
sempre è vero che lo stop arredi sono
atterrato ma perché dura solo un'oretta
la storia di vodafone dovete votare se
sono degno del giocatore zoom con con
power insomma voi date non sono una
bottiglia d'acqua e votate dal dalle
storie di vista grandi vodafone.it
vodafone.it scrivete e votate ovviamente
dotato di vi prego ragazzi anche se sto
con che sono due killer nella lobby e
quindi qualcosa già sto facendo niente
male
e poi comunque vi ricordo che stiamo
giocando questo molto importante stiamo
giocando terzetti e siamo in due vuol
dire che tutti gli altri sono in timida
treno giamenti in da due quindi siamo
partiamo svantaggiati e non è colpa
nostra non farti 3 nella lobby che non
sono mai morto vale qualcosa già no
means piano fare niente mi dispiace io
sto provando a dire un po di acqua al
mio mulino domandare a noi posso dare è
quello è pure tranquillo solitamente
perché i posti nominali cosiddetti poi
point of interest quelli con il nome
scritto sopra sono i posti dove di
solito c'è più gente ok sono cioè tipo
hospital e tipo till the tower ci si
lancia tutti sul tetto e parte tutti a
pistolettate tipo già un mix sul tema va
bene però chiamiamola il punto arancione
ok va bene
perfetto quando voi dimmi tu il via
perché qui siamo a livello di motore si
chiama 321 di altre figure abbiamo
almeno un team di miss è una mia
la mia vecchia si dice non so parlare
impressione ha impressionato quando
infatti buzzi e le tv il paracadute dopo
un po inizia ad andare più in picchiata
e invece quando dio che lo tiri subito
invece va molto più orizzontale sono io
di pila come se tirasse uno slancio
abbiamo comunque ok ok non so se livelli
ragazzi si speriamo di fare john week
come si deve allora non è la causa di
affianca la mia ora vediamo se riesco ad
arrivare ma c'è una cassa ok della casa
dietro di me
seguendo la carico io vado via vado via
vado via paiato state le armi corribile
io che ho comprato non continuare a
correre che non ho armi non ho piastre
arrivo verso la situazione c'è una
piastra io volendo da costa però c'è la
celebrazione o allora rimango qui ok
raga queste buone ma l'ho chiamata 1
sotto casa mia maschera antigas ball
arriva o nella casa di fianco alla mia
io spero che non mi faccio male mentre
vendola the arrivo so io
però scappato deve uscire ne uscirai
dobbiamo andare in via dobbiamo dare
indietro
io prendo un'altra casa va bene questo è
venuta da io ma che cosa ma scuola ma mi
ha veramente aperto adesso arrivato
staccandosi rimando occhio ciao vogliono
ma guardato sono morto
non so neanche come facciano ormai non
mi faccio più domande arrivo a rievocare
no col pompa nulla avviato e ora che non
solo 18 con lo smalto ma i premi su
premi due volte shift di fa la corsa
quella più veloce che magari per passare
una strada così si penta sicura pure
quando era parti albula ce l'ha a destra
centrodestra ora è passato dal tuo
sponda destra e dietro di te
praticamente dove sei rinato tempo la
spesa maglia io odio la pistola dietro
vai a cazzotti stefano buono buono fai
così fai così ho avuto l'approvazione
del buon giorgio sono contento di
ritrovarlo
allora bella domanda devi scegliere due
in verità dovreste andare dove c'è una
ricerca tipo qua e non posso pagare
questo bengasi nome e non c'è il nome
maya e non vedo la ricerca io porca
vacca
intanto sono ancora col paracadute
limite io mi butto allora story mando io
di dire tipo di andare qualche c'è una
ricerca
ma io non le vedo se ricerche come fai a
vederle to hell di gabriela mappa a ok
per forza non è l'italia praticamente ok
sta arrivando è cioè penso che siamo
uguali a me non importa ma tu dici che
la ricerca c'è gente no di solito ok
gente qua ecco quindi la dobbiamo
prendere scappare via
abbiamo armi in croce è un ace lo lancia
come pagato arrivato dopo che la baio
entro l'anno tirato bene ma non possiamo
andare siamo aiuto non so che fa
dobbiamo dobbiamo andare assurdamente ok
siamo la macchina auguriamo per i no
perché ci stanno dando la caccia a
questi pdl che ottimo mercato non
possiamo che comprende la cassa perché
c'è un proprio un team di al giallo
cavare vabbè dai ragazzi però madonna ma
che cattiveria niente devo correre via
niente non li vedo né alzarle hanno
ammazzato solo persone che non fanno che
non ho mai visto world classic proprio
world classic però devo correre via
perché mi stanno seguendo per quello
nell'ultimo periodo giocavo molto di più
abbondante come ti dicevo perché
riesco a capire dove la più o meno amato
dalla gente cioè difficile una mozione
da dietro
sì ma questa qua un gioco con un
gameplay non realistico perché non è
realista il gameplay e grafica
realistica quindi non si capisce niente
si capisce niente sa non si capisce
niente c'è la dr
ma ne hanno tirato un altro per darmi la
calcia ma veramente stanno messi così
questo guarda guarda madonna senza il
mirino compositi di cattiveria ma non so
cosa fare perché questi mi stanno
seguendo per darmi la caccia ma come mai
non mi ma la mia allucinante
io l'ho tirato un altro web ma solo per
te che sì sì ma non ci hanno tirato
tregua bimbe ridà a 15 anno quello che
ti vedono a prescindere
buono poco dire sarti così scappi via
che possa fare tanto in questo momento
il rasoio
però almeno amore sì sì c muoverci muoio
non posso fare altro se sì quello che
stai scambiando la tua persona per la
mia mi fido di te fare mammamia fai
proprio bene arrivo per iorio devia
scappa proprio lontanissimo dove ti
porta il cuore non venire da me ok mi
porta liquore portali io non mi posso
muovere d'acqua soprattutto intorno poi
andare a fare la sfida se vuoi sono
andato completamente da un'altra parte
alla domanda cosa neanche descrivere io
ce l'ho accanto e sono gamper ato dietro
un angolo e non mi muove ma mia e non
posso fare altro devo aspettare che è
situazione dato che su cui è uno dei
pochi giochi che tendono p2 non lo puoi
fare se tipo se tutti e due cominciano
da spararsi ha sì perché anche se mi ri
meglio mori lo stesso lo stesso per il
fattore della però io pazzo
scusate che devo protti lan coltellino
rando che chi però alcune cose isterico
credo di beccarlo sicuramente vedrai
trappola la scritta che lo becco ok ok
ottimo nice
e quindi io soldi e restò anche te
appena mori immagino c'è da rifare
perché quel e non aiutato quindi mi è
andata bene
fortunatamente a meno che non si strinse
dai bene cosa che faranno sicuramente
però l'impressione si alti ma che ci
abbia più presto perché non è difficile
di tregua per due cristiani ma per uno
per uno non ancora qua non ci credo
preso il cosa non ci credono andare a
comprare una b e mi stanno continuo
dall'area credibile si sono fermati
fuori casa ad aspettarmi
niente o 900 cioè dove cerami tutte ste
gara quelle sono morto porca vacca e va
beh vedo se le scale sarti però trovava
con calma dei fori solo ti fa con calma
prendendo tempo sono andati a comprare
un altro web in uno store lì vicino il
capello si preparò allucinante 2000 dai
che forse la donna anzi limitese stoffa
cagate io non so se c'è un bene non ti
preoccupare
vendola poi prima cosa piace perché
spiccio bono dai dai dai dai dai dai dai
dai 4mila euro soldi qua c'è niente
come poi è tornato prima giusto
preparata non c'è una cassa ok novi
sfiga poi c'è la 450 500 arrivo shop più
vicina e li stai attento perché potrebbe
esserci qualcuno ovviamente si è quindi
stato mammamia ragazzo sudando manco
fossi nella guerra
vedo vedo un po di gioco in questo
stream schneider esatto non ha idea c'è
mi stavano proprio simbolo dire accesi e
hanno perso di vista quando ti arrestato
no noi soffermati tutti fuori due si
sono fermati fuori la porta è andato a
prendere il web è facile così il buon
povero né humbert humbert gambe comeback
a fare smistava vabbè tanto dai primi 50
ci siamo già recordman quando vuoi io
vengo da fare vado a fare la prendo la
taglia se la taglia lo sciacallo
desideri in elicottero caro no guarda
eviterei di mancino potente elicottero
ok ok città cerca ignorati fareste case
come sono fatte lancia con tutte uguali
ma se io credo le piastre comunque sono
abbastanza simone troppo le mammole due
parole proprio tranquillo tranquillo va
bene per spero o tele dolce non mille no
no no no ma tranquilli
ecco uno faceva classico localizzato ok
ok andiamo a prendere l'altro avevo c'è
un po di soldi che cacchio
un m4 no ho trovato un para bellum
non so quale è una copertura che cacchio
allora che metti con hicks si no
è un arma x 9 mm va male qualcosa al mp5
allora mi sono un attimino che hanno
sotto quello che ho visto che sono una
lista contenente lo chiamava era gaio
prega per me che non ci sia qualcuno che
mi mira da sopra qui 90 per cento le
volte che salì la fune c'è un tizio
sdraiato in fermo che si guardi non c'è
non c'è non sono buono buono altri
equipaggiamenti amo a farne un altro che
ci prendiamo la cassa almeno poi quel
armi nostre si ragiona perché veramente
queste sono le armi veramente quelle
povere viola taglia il ceo sta già
andando a guardare
no abile sulla taglia una brezzolina
tranquillo tranquillo sbagliato io
finiamola di trovare altri due spicci ma
dentro è tutto sudato qua dentro
chi sto seguendo come un cagnolino
programmi ma davvero non riusciamo a
trovare quanto serve 500 niente ma una
presa in giro
dovrai già controllato sopra hanno
contato una mazza no no ma credo che ce
la marcia normale perché sono due
mitragliette in realtà ecco la sfida e
mamma mia quanto quanto a te piace la
skill e se quella la sfida canora
sfiderà il nome della skin sorry
l'arma qual è la raffica di tre come si
chiama io vado
lasciamo pure i soldi alfa hamas dopo le
note quello che in mano e lode le droghe
non è male già fa un botto di danno e
difficile da controllare ma fa un botto
non lo tengo grazie siamo la cassa
cecchino mai mai mai tanto io prendo la
r almeno non scomodiamo io me ne abbiamo
fantasma
io prendo la r e stringente non sta
certo prendo pure delle piastre se ne
vuoi extra sono qua
ciao a tutte allora come facciamo a se
vogliamo fare una cosa intelligente
sarebbe macchiato di noi arrivano ok che
ridono arriva bisogna mano non l'ho
fatto
dove sta no
hanno creatura poi la granata in mano
non ci voleva dobbiamo sparare è va bene
a me mi hanno tirato con il lanciarazzi
peccato quando sei sembra conte zombies
praticamente quando hai preso in mano
quella che era nata ho detto perché alla
grande ma dobbiamo sparare
perché io non so perché aveva il trophy
aver trovi travica l'ha sentita pure lui
mannaggia a me che mi è arrivato con
stessa cosa quando vuoi alexandra parti
anche un ex next to you next no secondo
me era gara c'è potenziale in un'altra
vita che foto in doppia ma più che altro
abbiamo una sfiga che allo start ci sono
venuti addosso proprio abbiamo
facilitato niente a tim è dispiaciuto
visto correre preso un action pax
madonna non sapevo che fare che riley
che c'era una dieta io continuavo a
correre per cercare di portarli verso di
me più che invece veniva da te proprio
così vabbè si fa quel che si può
grazie hanno votato comunque ragazzina
l'hotel text con ex sta andando mannaia
ovvio però nella lobby di tutto a posto
è il problema è quando scendiamo in
campo discorso io nell'allenamento si
sarebbe stato bravo poi basta
si può essere bravo vai vai vai ma è
difficile questo gioco poi siamo qui in
due la cosa più difficile quello è
veramente impossibile prova questa che
una volta ti racconto questa ho perso
perché si è chiuso sopra il centro
commerciale no non potevi salire no non
potevo uscire cioè potevo scendere ed
eravamo quelli sopra quindi di base hai
vinto solo che noi non avevamo la
maschera antigas e quindi siamo lì sotto
si quelli sotto se gli ho detto ma
scendiamo al massimo perché secoli hanno
una maschera hanno vinto la masca cioè
ma la maschera antigas veramente
importante mai mercato serve 90 per
cento di volte serve solo per la fine
per cui camperanno esageratamente e
quindi ce l'hai per rimanere un po più
invito per cercare io per darti il tempo
di curarti magari nero mannaie però
compenso
almeno secondo cielo arrivato dobbiamo
dobbiamo per cercare portato a vittoria
da almeno 1 almeno uno
ieri nokia così con di vittorie qua
tutte sconfitte con una vittoria ben più
o meno lei per me è il problema è che
veramente veramente tosto come hai visto
quelli là che ci soprende addosso a uno
sono riuscito a farlo per me hanno
tirato tipo lanciarazzi non so che mi
hanno tirato di radon fiero aveva
buttato giù subito non puoi far niente
ci sta dove prima di andare in quanto
imposto dove vuoi ti seguo vai vai ti
sei con la stecca proprio se riusciamo a
portare a vittoria in soccorso della
vita pagavamo andiamo là il sistema
trofino non so neanche che cosa sistema
trophy è una sorta di torretta che mette
a terra che distrugge tutti gli
esplosivi o un granata che ti arrivano
addosso è molto forte però cioè
stazionario cioè dove lo tiene di male
c'è un'aria una piccola area 321 vice
dott
sperando questo giro di non ritrovarmi
dei maiali che mi rincorrono come dei
pazzi basta basta cioè proprio avete
rotto
no che non è visto la scena di prima di
tutti e tre mi seguivano io che cambia
vocata in continuazione premi giornate
quando giochi come fai ti succede spesso
sta cosa mi succede spesso è proprio per
questo che ora mettono a streamer è così
che la gente di papà diciamo dopo un po
farlo e se no è infatti la sera
infattibile qual è arrivata nessuna è
teoricamente buono abbiamo tempo per
aiutare ma sempre occhio perché potrebbe
essere qualcuno
ma quante volte qui non c'è nessuno è
così spesso la gente senza una casa
per questo sul tetto
non ho trovato un fucile di precisione
corsa cremisi 4 un'amica male o nel male
non c'è chi ha meno meglio che non
averlo che non averlo certo ok
pochissimi soldi però io ho trovato
niente non c'è la maschera pagamento è
solo 2000 è già una di maschera sempre
impegnato una perdente hp dopo valutare
la velocità della luce sperando di
trovare qualcosa di decente ma mattino
io qua ci sono un po di assalto e poi
c'è un nome 4 blu marital sommesso bene
nuovi quest'anno non so di sull 1
piastre no direi che sono a posto
mitraglietta bella preferisco il
cecchino va lasciate lavoro sporco del
cecchino quando è quello non so come è
non so come riesco a farlo con centro il
tornello simpatico ad ora fermi qua ok
maschera antigas e maschere antigas
abbiamo trovato abbastanza devo dire o
chiudiamo allaccia una macchina che sta
avendo verso di noi
la potremmo fare stanno e da solo quello
lì è entrato in quell'edificio qual era
la nel ping sulla macchina che non si
vede
stanno combattendo lo sappia quindi
sappiamo che qui c'è un team
questa ragazza non la voglio tirarmi
unico niente però avete capito
poi c'è una media c'è sempre un sacco
mi raccomando
lasciamolo dov'è scende a sta scendendo
proprio del paracadute l'ha chiamato a
sé poi possiamo andare là dietro che si
si si si
mario eccoci lo pratica di uno
madonna
non sopra di noi hanno fatto dietro
infatti manca un lato di un altro ancora
sopra io ho confermato il tuo vero
niente
ha più fatto bravo ho tirato il silenzio
di tomba per niente però va beh sì che
non si fatica buono buono buono buono
così le persone altri tg
mamma mia che rischio connessi così come
detto la mitraglietta arriva un veicolo
verso di noi vero che si lancerà b si
guarda che non va in ora noi però
spaventato dietro c'è i soldi prendo la
cassa io arrivo aspetta per tempo se
trovi i soldi ce li ho provati trovati
più trovati trovati no io lo amo io
allora se prendi pure il self res se
vuoi qualcosa che magari tipo di auto
rianimare buono buono buona cosa per noi
vai non credo io ritornerai sopra la
ritorniamo controllarsi ss 7 ter iene
esco vamonos arrivo su pc già qualcuno
qua dentro fidate intervita defilata le
case dove stanno noi nella visto con la
coda dell'attrice cece mamma mia quante
scoperto sto detto non mi piace per
niente
beh settimana stanza velocemente non c'è
quindi aver paura non chiamiamolo
salaria prove su sedia mirandoli lì c'è
una finestra dietro sembra clear la
programmazione cercato di essi mai un
cerchio con termico a voi mio no no no
tranquillo valutare sotto a sto punto
intanto non c'è tanto da che posso fare
con cecchino con termico ma meno odio il
termico e perché mometti no non l'ho
messo io l'ho trovata ma di giro e
giusto per dire tanto con cielo almeno
c'è un cecchino
io forse ma allora dobbiamo prima
dovremo aspettare questo punto la zona
aspettiamo tanto che si esca ascoltare
qualcuno che sta prendendo per le
piastre stanno facendo qualcosa qua
davanti a me quando non ti ami vedi il
ping giallo vuol dire che stanno facendo
una cattura
ok no sono qua davanti e spediti via
madonna comune sopra ha mancato però
niente che mi fa sarebbe da provare il
push amo una sotto qui a destra la
nostra grande raduno 1 sotto esattamente
sotto di me ma esatta mai lo caga troppo
caro la marcia stavo quasi fatto di
partire bene che c'è gulan che almeno
parlava ma da quello c'è pieno di tutto
qua come ritorno indietro mi stanno
seguendo
ma niente non ce l'ha fatto male non
celebra davanti possiamo fare era lo
stesso che prima tra l'altro mi già due
volte gli ho sparato
non vi è rimasto niente scott può dire
ai ripari per i quali la tua arma quindi
sabato i parenti poi prendere un
cecchino ieri prenderti la tua arma da
buono macchine game più di tutto lì a
piastre di tutto di più e mi sta
tranquillo maschera tutto è stanno
arrivando sono molto vicini
oddio dove sono merda può andarti a
riprendere il tutto durante su di me che
cacchio era il telo pinguini come quanti
giorni questa cosa questa causa ma
guarda non so dove secondo la minaccia
due però non siamo qui distrutto non ho
mai visto niente
io non ho visto una massa dopo controlla
meglio per la tv la verità
ciao davanti e soprattutto dove quello
blu fatto 14 subito o bell 8 cecchino
della rubato ben 1 hanno fatto ma
l'altra sotto di me ma io ci arrivo un
cazzo aspetto
ok fatto un altro
e la prima metà non ha segato però
soprattutto il terzino blu di nuovo la
primario
e lì dentro lo vedo ricevuto si no
puro calcato la terra anche bono un
altro che spara alto e sotto una volta
lì quello si auto ressa ora con la sopra
e si sia l'autore se l'auto si e gia
autore stato ma non ti devi preoccupare
quindi se riusciamo a tirare giù anno
correndo per prendere le piastre ma non
lo show quest'anno allo shock
ok arrivo oggi io non ho fatto zona
manolo craccato fatto lega chi è finito
quasi morte così molto bravissimo mi
devo curarmi inaugurare d'amore che
nascondono qualcosa perché ce n'è un
altro cercare una persona aia e dove
cacchio momento è questa qua aveva
malumore naja ma non moriva non l'ha già
vicina figura nel gozzo faccio il gulag
al volo fa 5 la gallina preoccupà va
bene va bene va bene
per il resto erano troppi è vero ma la
donna al momento di colpire momento di
colpire ma non avere regole non mi
entrano i colpi non so che fare sparano
nel tradizionale telaio vista è
veramente allarme ma ho preso comunque
incredibilmente al palasharp credibile
next dai un calo di prima che non gli è
entrato il color posso ancora rosicando
per che l'avrei ucciso non messo un
workshop che si è incredibile torri
colpa mia ma leader figura ci manca solo
manager mi sono fatto prove consigli
lione hai fatte otto ci mancherebbe
comunque visto che manca al 5 minuti ma
adesso hanno visto sta roba nuova anapo
tar mi dicono va beh io abbiamo lo
stesso al voto vinciamo e non possono
votare perché finito allora ragazzi
mancano meno di cinque minuti
praticamente per andare a votare e
solista grandi vodafone vodafone.it se
volete sapere il nome completo potete
votare se fallisce stato abbastanza
bravo in questa sfida ci passa ragazzi
si faranno passare in finale 1 svuotate
mix della serie per 3 minuti della serie
sapete già che da questa vinciamo quindi
votare prima perché dopo non potete però
questa la vinciamo lo dico io quindi
potete andare a votare dai cattivi che
la posta
megan lucky
ma tanto tu hai più account che sei al
110 o è il massimo
no il massimo e 155 ma ogni stagione si
esalta ecco perché non è male che l'idea
del reset
devo dire la verità ci stanno ci sta di
brutto come cosa momento comunque ora
vogliamo riandare sempre live allora
siccome vuoi te realtà come vuoi che ti
porta l'importante è riuscire a parti
che non c'è gente perché ti giulio con
la pistolina proprio come sa come ma poi
non so se è visto non spara dove miri
per diventare la pistola
solo il primo colpo quindi un bordello
all'uci manca si deve andare sentimento
come far vincere stava pasta niente la
fa certe teorie o ma vedo come un sacco
verso di lavoro di giocare a porta ei
ragazzi qua ra qua ancora ciò
possibilità perché non vi costruì come
ho detto perché porta e papà non c'è
speranza prescindere perché non so posso
dire niente quindi anche volendo posso
provare perché l'ho fatto ma ora si
divertì restivo tra forme come l'hanno
cambiato vero hanno fatto dei
cambiamenti proprio pricklepants però è
invece sai switchando di più oppure io
sto switchando di più ciò che mi va di
giocare l'ho presa un pochino più
filosofica un po di ba voglio giocare a
qualcosa pure più divertente come cosa
le persone si divertono molto di più
comunque tutto questo cambia perché
un codino come ti dicevo ieri perché
quello faceva quello fa è nato ma ora
ora se tornasse a giocare ora si
divertirà e stimolo per quanto fatto un
cambiamento al match making io pure sono
tornata di giocarci dopo che non giocava
four nights da due mesi tre mesi lo
aveva abbandonato per un po di mesi
perché non mi sono piaciute le gare
scelte ok di vita cioè una frode allora
questa raga che vedevo di la partenza lì
dunque sempre così nome po nella
abbastanza liera buona la partenza alle
dobbiamo solamente aggiustare bene
quando capitano questi file c'è fi di a
mosca cosa utile palla coppa per ragazzi
il microfono technology il famosissimo
leggendario microfono la capisce
microfono tanto anche solo perché il
fatto che sei caduto due ore prima ne fa
capi quanto che c'è gente resta la
stessa andati avanti o dietro e davanti
davanti
dovrò pinga teniamoci però applicato
esagerato chi opera di qua non c'è
nessuno l'estate teoricamente non ho
visto nessun cadere insediato perché
dove c'è la paglia praticamente yes
abbiamo un pochino arrivo di sudare in
fretta aiutato già a casa gialla e
quella sì che tutti poi se poi ti può
fare tutto un lato della strada al mi
faccio il lato sinistro di parlato da
essere stato perché così va tutelato da
occhio che c'è gente lì dunque ma poi
aiutato ad esempio al caval non ho fatto
ma ciò nel peccato arrivo o mio dio io è
il vorresti rally fatti e questi era io
l'ho capito quando mai detto sono alla
taglia la taglierà era dietro i nomi
sopra noi son caduti qua c'è dove stavo
entrando io poi non sono di qua che ci
stava sacca per un nuovo escludere non
vinca locali via via via prè dieta
località paura quanti soldi abbiamo già
un sacco
ok e paura me li sono trovati a un
centimetro dalla faccia stata da parte
loro il girone lose my two drone in
verità per trovare ci mettiamo c4
soprano mandia sì sì no no me kamikaze
soldi quanto abbiamo non sicuri di aver
dato tutto è la casa dove ero io forse
non tutto ok abbiamo i soldi possiamo
andare a comprare su ok
cadendo non tanto di altri due assalto
non mi piace mai un rpg per non saper né
leggere né scrivere lo tengo gli rpg da
knuble tifoso frega anche sempre v2
esplosivo lanciagranate e non mero un
peto non sto scherzando
non ero ecco gli altri due soldi qua c'è
parte ora mi lasci son villa di fran
vedo abbiamo le armi la volendo rapio
beta l'annuncio da una lapide falsi ci
mettono molto di me fanno luton e carlo
sotto ok
si mettono al volante perché arriva ad
arte di soldi
no guarda barbare parola di troppo fa
troppo rito sul core amico mio non
abbiamo fidate che io me la merito
ancora meno 14 k eccoci allo stato
ho chiesto delle piante riscatto era una
bomba del rais allo no che cosa deve gas
noi siamo a posto lo sono state per
respirare sempre al microfono
nove le voci aiutano le cuffie nemesi
quella del più lewis allora arriva su di
noi uno davvero e mandare a combattere
sono d'accordo ai agri arrivo faccia un
puntino lavezzi sì la sua opera
ho visto una marziana
sono due team che combattono giacché non
c'è chi va bene ma lo vuoi totò fatto
uno morto un team si è spremuto primo no
no no non è 18 non c'è chi se lo vuoi
totò perché sicura ma non è più il tuo
cecchino lo ha capito però non vuol dire
ma scusami sei tu che stai facendo la
challenge cup
se vuoi che lanciò le armi lo so che ha
ragione però un po come quando tra il
professore la pena gli fai tu il calcolo
io capisco niente
la fragilità stiamo andando hai presente
quando la profetico reggeva il compito e
dice a questo si fa così così così così
e poi gli davi quello che ho fatto lei
no non voglio fare quello e la sua
collana comodo dire la vera smesso con
il concetto è quello che ci sta una che
è cascato lì un po più avanti la nave
con questo non è si stanno avvicinando
potrebbero mi metto su una grande sogno
credevano che separa cosa dato lo vedo
l'ora craccato la crack che ti avrebbero
sentiero dalla comunque sono la hanno
ascoltato sicura dopo il ping blu è
perfetto is easy quanto vi vorranno
dietro craccato di nuovo nokia che
misero in faccia e stato bellissimo
l'aria vogliono goffin bel gesto
fatemi un meme lasciate fare il punto
poi il suo video i punti danno così
fastidio se non avevo mai per terra con
una mazza non ti pongono una mazza io ho
un addio bravi fa più danneggato sta
sempre là comunque sono ma come arrivano
da sinistra nostrana grande ok
arriva ora tranquilla iniziare basta che
riguardi sibello solo paura
stiamo tenendo in questo momento un
avvocato non può volevo uscire ma niente
ci rinuncia no non sto più spostando non
so dove sono qua davanti a me una lama e
l'altra siano fondati via tutto capito
ripeto se vengo dal combattere bugialli
e abbiamo con shirley prima quando
lavoro cadauno che avevamo due figure
non sapeva da solo vado a scippare le
auguro perché dove l'on e ho perso
veramente tanto stanno sul tetto alcuni
non c'è un cecchino beccato brancato
hanno colpito meglio un po levato robe
tre su tre
bono ragazzi potete votarmi sul volta
con forse non potete però fate non c'è
ancora speranza corrette in questo
istante che sono agli sgoccioli e è
bella domanda ma non la puoi andarci un
po addosso ma non so come andare perché
non avendo cecchino io devo sparare con
il fucile d'assalto e il problema è che
ho due caricatori e in questo momento
beh quelli di corso troppa almeno quelli
magari parma si stanno sparando con
un'altra squadra
sì quello che proviamo a prendere e bici
si dipana che c'è uno la dovrà vedere se
riesco a beccarlo
spero che se lo prendiamo quello per
matthew allora andiamo lì c'è pure un
cecchino lo aveva destato mammamia
guarda come sta fermo come un palo
quello scorrevano fermo come un palo
facendo in giro estremo
tanto ragazzi ho messo adesivi a caso
giusto hdr non guardate non quelli non
vota tedeschi mero brutto horribilis ma
niente ti può prendere l'arma che
proviamo i loro se riesco posso prendere
la mia arma o che hanno preso panico
gigi ha riparato o addio non ho capito
porca vacca che male che male dove non
era tanto zanier e un ragazzo abbia
motivato sopra per fai dare anche gli
altri in giro in mezzo al campo verso
una meta
e bobby mezzo punto sotto di noi a
destra madonna una struttura a destra
non possiamo stare l'hack è male laddove
non ha beccato dall'altra parte di
collina mila pure dalla non ho partito
dato che una sparato quello o mio dio
che shot i cani non hanno cadeau arriva
pure la fama arriva la zona
vediamo la macchina ci andiamo per forza
andiamo tutto prima pianista allora
doveva mente ma quelli sono morti che
che fine hanno fatto scusi
no sono la nostra destra parlare della
destra lui ha messo in clinica a rai1 di
cura di è nono con piastre come mio zio
per il nice
o mio dio svegliato nell'erba mannaggia
questo ci ha lanciato da quando mandò
mitch averci sì ma era sdraiato
nell'erba ho visto la mia visuale era
breve
vabbè rai come ultima potrebbe essere
ancora positiva ci abbiamo ancora noi
andato bene non sapevo che era allo
sport con cate toccate tempo di brillare
a ok tu sei già morto cacchio essi non
sapevo dove andavo dietro un angolo
ferrari non avevo capito è ripartito
subito la prova trattamenti cation a me
non mi stavano a partire è in attesa
dell'avversario preparano a combattere
raga niente ora vediamo in mano a mia la
partita il pie ballava al momento di
brillantina ma come sei orgoglioso ma
[ __ ] dov'è
non lasciamo la pistola fidati che per
me come sarà come se avessi pugni non
l'ho mai lo shock che hai fatto quello
che liberò detto capo non lo ha preso e
invece ti ho creduto detto ciao illudo
pure io ero tutto carico davvero carico
e regalandosi però però in quattro
partite ho fatto tre killer e tutte
tranne cura che però non è mamma non
erano nè semplice montana ma pure perché
c'è lo skill bass match making quindi
paradossalmente farace radio positivo
qua perché non mi trovo proprio gli
spari l'eroe però vabbè md e di è
difficile questo perché non si vedono i
nemici cm e stavo aspettando 1 non so
chi è mai bello il nostro team no e
quello che ti ha ucciso qualcuno
ecco che allora niente non voglio e
quello che trovate sempre fermi al
giocatore un linguaggio offensivo
ok niente raga basta che vedevo di
abbiamo provato però potete comunque
votare su rubata fornita in realtà non
lo so se è ancora appena stato dovrebbe
ancora attiva la votazione avrebbe raga
grazie alla connessione come sempre che
ci permette di fa queste cose
incredibili e anche se al gulag non dico
vi ringrazio per aver partecipato alla
live e ringrazio anche il buon giorgione
marche organizza per fare il moro
gatling perché ieri mi sono arrivato è
stato veramente conoscere moriero no no
in realtà ora che te l'ho detto nome
come una settimana di training mi sono
proprio divertito completamente dentro
lo schermo tutto minguzzi trovargli
importante che ci siamo divertiti anche
oggi chi se ne frega dai riguarda
ringraziamento a bordo
grazie pure a tutta la cia perche sono
qui si chiama il board della facciata ma
in realtà non ce la fanno e vj i fan di
genere fra i tanti noi ci sentiamo fammi
sapere
va bene il bacio azione bye bye
ciao a tutti